what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
today we're doing something very very
different and very exciting
today we're learning about the future of
bim whilst interviewing some of the
specialists in
the bim industry so without further ado
let's start the introductions
and start this video
so first of all thank you for taking the
time to speak with me today i know we've
kind of been arranging this for a little
while now and we finally
managed to put it all together for those
people that are watching this video
on youtube and everywhere else would you
just like to introduce yourselves what
your role is
and who you are really okay i can start
um hello everyone
i'm fleur i'm a bim product specialist
at brixis so as a day job
i demo the product i help solve
requests from customers and that's
basically what i do in brixis i'm
melissa i'm also we together in the same
team floor and i
um we help our clients with questions
we demo to prospects okay well i try to
organize this meeting today to
talk about the future of bim as much as
possible and i try to make it as
interactive with
my audience at least so a couple weeks
ago on youtube i posted a series of
polls
for them to answer and to understand the
best
of the system that they're using and how
they see the future of bim
so the first question i posted to
everybody was just a generic question
trying to understand what type of
software they're using
the results came in relatively
non-surprising
we had 25 percent of users still using
2d software
um so just straight 2d lines 56 of them
using 3d software
and only 19 actually calling themselves
bim pros so i guess my first question to
you guys
is why would anybody want to switch
from just standard 2d and 3d programs
all the way to a full-blown
bim system all right i can answer this
question
so um first of all i think
a lot of these people who um yeah might
not want to switch in the first place
um to bim might think think it is
because it's just a hype it's gonna pass
over
anyway um and basically i want to tell
them that at least i
believe strongly that it's just not only
a hype it's more than that
and for me it's really something
which prepares us for the future and it
helps us for example
do analyzes of buildings we can model
something
in 3d we can add all the data that's
needed we can do some
analyzations on that um and that before
we
enter the workstation so it it makes the
work
place uh the the construction site a
safer place in my opinion
um because we are more prepared when we
go to the construction site
so that's um why i think that um yeah
the the the error rate that you have
in um in bim is a way less than you
would have when you're trying to
mix 2d um drawings together and make
sure that all the views are aligned and
so on
so basically i think people um now
drawing in 2d or 3d
um of course they they have a valid
working method
um and at brix's we also try to
[Music]
help them to go from this 2d or 3d
workflow to bim
by not making the um the the step too
high of changing to bim so your workflow
you can still keep it the same you can
still
start in 2d and draw it up and and take
it to 3d
and then convert it in a bim model as
you uh go along so
in my opinion why is this very
useful to do that is because um
yeah you really want to make your models
future proof
and when you're have a client coming up
to you
asking hey can you do bim project for me
and you have to say
oh i'm still working in 2d i i guess
that's not really
how you want to be approached and when
you can say yes we
we are working on bim as well um you can
step
on to the train and you can make your
models uh future proof
uh so that's the main message which i
want to give to people and
um it can happen in a not so difficult
way and where you are using your current
workflows
just integrating some data along the way
uh which makes them
yeah more useful uh later on your models
in the bim industry the bim industry is
obviously evolving very quickly and it's
rapidly changing especially with
technology changing so quickly
what do you think the biggest trend is
in the bim industry for both 2d and 3d
industries
yeah that's an interesting question i
mean
i i i will take this one as well um if
it's okay
but melissa will talk for sure when when
we're uh further in this
interview that's interesting because we
see a lot of trends in the construction
industry
often has said that the construction
industry is
one of the slowest ones to adapt to
technological trends
but i do see some promising stories and
one of
my favorites is the digital twins
so what does what is it um for the
watchers who might not
um be fully acquainted with the term
digital twin
um that um you
basically model your building um
in a a twin an identical twin format on
your computer so you you have your
virtual
environment where again you can do all
these kinds of analyzations and so on
um and we keep that in sync throughout
the life cycle of a building
and that um seems promising to me why
because
um you can actually see the um
the cost over a lifetime of a building
rather than just
um having it right away
just delivering it and not take your
hands
or take your hands off because yeah if
you
maintain this digital twin over time and
there are also techniques to monitor for
example shifts in in high-rise buildings
to to monitor
are they not uh going to um to to
fall over let's say so that's um a
interesting um development i see in the
aec industry and um
yeah i think digital twins combined with
virtual reality must be
um something which shapes the future
yeah i know there's been a lot of talk
and
social media and influences about
digital twins especially now because
people are starting to take these
digital twins and turn them into
a business or a marketing strategy in
itself so it's no longer just
you have your architect who does your
documentation they hand over the project
and you have as constructor drawings
now you actually get somebody on board
to monitor that building and forever
hold a digital twin so
it's it's definitely a big leap forward
i think in that section of the industry
for sure
the next question i asked to everybody
on youtube
was what is the most important for you
so obviously every architectural
software has a variety of different
tools and different
specialities and what surprised me
actually
out of everything was the fact that 55
of the votes
said 3d visualization was the most
important element to them
whilst 26 percent said drafting tools
and
only 20 said the objects and libraries
it's interesting because drafting tools
helps you actually
build the building make the money get
more clients
whereas the objects and libraries make
the visualization better
so that one threw me off a little bit
but that's okay
um as you're in the visualization
specialist team
is it obvious users are looking for
better visualization tools and plugins
and how do you see bricscad competing in
this field with years to come
i think one of the things about
visualization is it's something
graphical it always keeps
that the nice touch uh
for marketing and for clients often
clients
don't don't have that feeling with a 3d
drawing so having a visualization helps
them to see where the project is going
and to avoid those misunderstanding
between the architect
and the client so um where do we see a
brisket
competing on this we listen to the
demand from our users
and we try to create the the best
pipeline between the different
platforms our biggest priority is
geometry first so we want to make sure
that
that is taken care and we know that
there's already
other solutions out there that do a
really good job and
such as the or latest integrations with
lumion
and tremotion and we also have already
already for a few last year was enscape
so i think for now i think our users
will be pretty happy with
what we have to offer and we will see in
the future
what it what comes next and and we
continue listening to the the users
personally i've shifted towards the twin
motion plug-in for me because it's
easier than any inbuilt rendering engine
um
and slowly the focus is moving towards
unreal engine
because unreal engine does have quite a
lot of realistic
ray tracing capabilities even though it
takes a lot longer to be able to
actually
get to your finished product it can
produce a lot better quality
so i guess my next question to you guys
is ray tracing is actually becoming
the key demand in the field and how do
you see brix cad
utilizing this technology in the future
um well um
just to go back a little bit on the
collective since we're not really a
engine we can render a little bit so you
can see
a few things here and there but the
purpose behind
is not to really be a 3d rendering
software it goes back to making these
pipelines for
the other softwares such as like you say
yourself
so to emotion they already have a better
uh version to
go from to emotion to unreal so you can
take it to the next level
if um i know we already had a few um
users saying yeah but it's not
photorealistic enough that yeah don't
worry
you can't take it to the next level if
you want to and
it's not even the the if you take it to
for example to real it's not only to to
make it even
realistic but then you can create a
whole environment
for the users to interact with and not
even
for uh to make it photorealistic but
also even if it's just
uh pure solids they can create a virtual
world where different stakeholders can
come in together
and talk about the project without
having to fly
to the location itself tracing is indeed
a
high demand now a lot of people it goes
a lot faster
the rendering you get better results
but even before we had uh the
exporting we supported already for a
while the fbx
and the collider so they could even take
it to blender
where they already also support the
right tracing so there's
there's lots of options for our users to
to benefit from that technology the
whole reason
we use visualization tools is to
actually
better design and provide better
services to our clients which you
touched on briefly
i guess it'd be interesting to find out
what your opinion is
on and how we can enhance the client's
experience
so for example because twin motion and
unreal are
very quick and very simple to do you can
very easily start
rendering very early on you don't have
to finish the
design completely and then give them the
final product moments before it's about
to go to construction and then they want
to change everything
so in your opinion do you think the
future of ray tracing is helping
us design and create 3d visualizations
earlier on
so clients can have a better experience
at the end of the day
ray tracing i wouldn't look it up i mean
i wouldn't think of
of a way to to help your
your race association it's just a
technology that is to
work more efficient uh like i said
you know before if you run uh back then
i would say maybe three
years ago if you wanted to render
something you had to wait
uh quite a long long long time and also
uh the denoising the all the all this
stuff is
to work more efficient and
have a result a lot faster and also
minimizing the budget that you put in
because
often lots of architects didn't want to
really invest
on this photorealistic because it just
it was too time-consuming
and it was too it cost too much and they
figure out that the clients as long as
they have some
some materials and something that
simulate what they
the end result would be they were happy
enough but now we can
give them something better now we can
in in such a fast uh like with twin
motion all you have to really is just
press a button
and you have already a virtual
environment so
okay in that sense then it facilitates
a little bit more um to analyze a few
things such as the shading where the sun
is
are you happy with with how the the the
song comes in in certain areas
but the ray tracing i see a more of an
efficiency
now i guess this is a bit of a off-topic
question and sorry about this
but do you guys at brix cad actually
have the opportunity to talk to people
at unreal engine and twin motion and
luminance
to have your opinion presented to them
and have your
voices heard to be able to actually
create what you want to create in their
software
yeah i didn't follow closely the lumia
but i did follow uh closely the two
motion
and yes we had a direct uh connection
they were very
very helpful uh and every now and then
whenever we spotted a bug
or things were a bit different or
we wanted to behave a bit differently
they
um yeah there were easy access
they were willing to work with us
cannot complain i was actually very
pleased and the surprise of
how fast the collaboration was because i
think within the
three or four months everything was uh
ready to go
okay um i guess we'll step away from
visualization now and move towards
parametric design parametric design is
something
i've been fascinated about since i was
at uni and it's something that can
create
incredible things it is time consuming
but
rewarding at the same time parametric
design is is something we truly use in
big firms it's not something we use
in little firms and i've worked in both
i've
now worked in a smaller firm it's
probably more of a medium firm
and we're trying to push into the
parametric design but it's
hard to convince people that it's of
value
similar to how visualization was
previously it was
wasn't of value because it took too long
and clients were happy with
a little material here and there how do
you see parametric design in the future
stepping away from just these large
firms
to be able to actually be integrated
into a smaller firm and to help speed up
the documentation process i guess yeah
that's
an interesting question and i as
i'm a very parametric
like parametric design enthusiast and
generative design enthusiast
um i i will take this question um
so also same like you i
have been interested in this since my
university
studies i have been introduced there to
parametric design and i guess
that's for a lot of people the first
touch they
have with parametric design but in
brixis i could elaborate
that passion a little bit further so
that
i was actually still working as a
student here in brixis
and i was yeah i was
given the tasks of designing something
designing the conference building
actually or the conference model train
station
if you look it up it's from a few years
back or two years back
and i was designed to to design this and
actually
what i've found out since then is that
parametric design has
a lot of um applications so not only
can you do these fancy rail station
canopies and and all of those things but
you can also
use it for some smaller scale
models or some smaller scale use cases i
particularly find it useful to use
parametric design
whenever you um want to
yeah want to make a unique situation you
want to make
you it needs to adapt to a unique
situation your design and i guess that's
in a lot of
small firm cases exactly the the fact
that you
will have your clients with all their
unique needs and all their unique
situations
and actually whenever you would use a
parametric design
in smaller scale projects you could
in my opinion have
this parametric design adapt to these
unique situations
yet um you reuse certain parts namely
the scripting that's behind it you
you just reuse it but by tweaking the
input parameters you can get
unique situations unique solutions
actually to
to the problem at hand so um i guess
that
um whenever you mix um
parametric and generative design
together with
a a good validation step of the
architects
you have these unique situations that
are actually fairly easy to to make
at first you might seem that you need to
invest a little bit of more time to
to design something by scripting it
but in the end you will be able to reuse
it you will be able to
um yeah adjust it slightly and one of
the
most use cases would be for example
stair designs
and you can you can adapt the stair
you can make it fully fit the situation
at
hand yet it doesn't have to cost as much
when you manufacture it because also in
the generative design process
you can immediately put in that step
where you
validate whether you can make it with
these standard diced parts so you just
use some standardized part to create a
very unique situation that's
all possible with a generative design as
well
and i think that is mainly where
smaller firms can benefit also another
example would be
wood framing in houses whenever your
window just changes slightly your wood
framing structure needs to
needs to adapt and that's also possible
by scripting
your you your wood framing that it just
adapts or your wall cladding if you want
a nice cladding design for one of your
interior walls
um like there are a lot of use cases and
and
i think on the bricks's website there
will be soon
and a special page for this so you will
be able to check out
some of the ideas but as well we are
collaborating with
mcneil here um to to integrate
grasshopper in bricscad and
um that's um also a wealth of
information
is on the mcneil community's sites
so um you you will find these
mind-boggling scripts
and that i always like to watch that uh
just as well and i guess that's a good
step for people to get interested in
it's just watching the nice results
i think staying on the smaller jobs
smaller firms topic
recently i've had a few jobs hit my desk
at least that
have been asked to be produced under bim
but
all the consultants on the team have
been a little bit older and a little bit
more set in their ways
so they've refused to
step up and use the bim software and
they just want to continue with their 2d
drawings and their 2d lines
some of them are still drawing by hand
so it's incredible to see these guys
still going and they
are a wealth of knowledge so you get so
much information out of them
but at the same time you're unable to
actually produce what the client wants
so how do you see those that older
generation i guess
of architects and engineers stepping
away from 2d
and embracing bim for me at least
maybe melissa can add to what i say here
but for me at least about showing them
the value of them
again and also the potential ease with
they can
they can start with it we would say
or at least i would say start simple
don't try to
start with your cla with a large client
saying okay can we do this entire site
or in in bim maybe that will be uh too
much of a step so i would start
say start simple um and um
just yeah let let you guide also
by by maybe the younger generation that
is um educated in it even maybe
the the older generation is just not
educated in it but you can learn a lot
from each other i think
um like bim has its flaws still as well
so
um for example when it comes to
detailing
pen and paper or maybe still um the
first tools that you should grab
so i think um whenever there is a nice
collaboration between these generations
they can actually
produce something which is very valuable
where you can have these
um talks about um how can we
transform what does that idea on paper
to
something which is um already starting
in bim
and i think in bricks in bricscad bim
we are like melissa already said we are
trying to pick up on that note um
with saying okay you can just start
modeling
you can start modeling a free form
almost um yeah you can push pull you can
extrude stuff
and then you can add the bim data later
like you don't have to worry about
getting everything right from the first
moment that you start your design
you can let it just flow according to
this
workflow that you um feel comfortable
with and i think that's
for me a big uh step to convincing um
everyone actually to to start with bim
is um
making them see the value first
educating them uh secondly and then
thirdly just
starting small and starting with some
simple projects
trying it out seeing what values it can
give them
and and so on so i don't know if melissa
had something to add
i think it's just a little bit
reinforcement of what like floyd you
said
to um i mean obviously is an old
generation so they know already about
bim for a long time
um but when it started it was revit uh
the one
mainly providing this a solution and
yeah revit is known for it not being so
easy
takes a lot of learning takes a lot of
budget especially
if if you have uh if you want to start
you
the complete firm to do it is really a
lot of cost
that they have to do uh to have
everybody on board
so maybe just to to have them see
that there's no longer uh revit uh
taking part on this bim
and the bim is not revit bim
is completely separate from revit revit
just provide you the solution for
for the model itself and
yeah maybe with uh or or solution
the fact that if it follows a little bit
of a logical
workflow you know if they can do 2d they
can then do 3d
and then they can just um
classify things however the one so
i mean i feel it's a bit uh
i mean maybe it might be seen as bias
but it makes a bit of sense
you know almost everybody starts with 2d
at school and then
you do some 3d and yeah the
bim actually if you look at our
perspective it's just classifying
uh the the the solids and then you can
extract the data however you want it
i think i think that's a good point
understanding that revit used to be
everything it used to be the only thing
people used in firms it was the best for
bim it was the best for everything
and it's just interesting how the world
progressed and how more and more
software has come out but
now you don't have to use revit you have
so many options
that everybody has an opinion of what
the best one is and
everybody always will and that's okay
but
i think that's probably one of the main
sticking points is when you do speak to
the older generation
they're just thinking revit in the back
of their head and it's so complex and
so difficult to use and so difficult to
learn so i think that's an excellent
point
but anyway that is all the questions i
had for you guys today
so you can relax and be stress-free you
don't have to be on camera anymore
um thank you so much for taking the time
i do appreciate it
okay okay cool thank you thank you for
the interview
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
i hope you enjoyed the interview with
melissa and floor and i hope you got
some
great valuable information out of it if
you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
because as always i'll see you next
monday